I can't tell the difference between my waking
life and dreams can i tell you a secret
your mind is a pendulum swinging between realities
your identities are not something to be feared
not something to be welcomed
this is the best worst day of my life rudy don't
remember our adventures or our life together god
i wish i could i'm now only on disney plus you're
in the middle of a personal crisis experience the
sixth episode of that your identities a mask to
hide the scars they are not something to be feared
but something to be welcomed you looked different
marvel studios night now streaming
Welcome backeveryone
this will be my full marvel moon knight
episode 3 trailer video there's a bunch of easter
eggs we learn a lot more about the mcu gods like
the enion here they're only one pantheon we'll
learn even more about the other mcu gods during
thor love and thunder so we'll break it all
down if you're brand new to the channel i'm
doing videos for all the episodes be sure to
subscribe to get everything and we're doing
a giveaway for disney plus memberships all you
have to do to enter just leave a comment on the
video with your favorite easter egg so far but
there's a bunch more footage of marc spector and
steven grant layla and arthur harrow in legit
egypt because the story just gone back there
specifically scenes of them that might be both
flashbacks and in present day also scenes of him
fighting arthur harrow and his men inside this
egyptian tomb which is probably where the moon
knight origin story happened or happens because
arthur harrow is looking for ammit's remains
that might be where some of the other earthly
remains of the rest of the aeneid pantheon remain
remember like their physical bones because
they actually did physically exist in the mcu
a long long time ago before they decided to
basically leave man like turn away from man and
take themselves to this other pocket dimension
called other void where they currently exist
that's why both konshu and ammit can only
physically interact with the mcu just very
slightly and through their avatars respectively
i guess if you want to talk about the eternals
because they came to earth 7 000 years ago that'd
be during the early dawn of civilization era
those mcu gods probably walked around earth around
that time a lot of that has to do with the way the
mcu gods exist and how they're different from
just really powerful cosmic beings so i'll talk
about that during the video too they said a lot of
the future moon knight episodes too are meant to
clarify that like how do the gods actually exist
how are they different than other regular powerful
cosmic beings are you thor the god of hammers
there are also a lot of scenes of him inside this
alternate pocket dimension other void where it
looks like he's inside one of the pyramids and you
see all these different types of people dressed
like ancient egyptians those are probably the
forms of the other legit mcu-enid gods remember
though technically this is only one pantheon one
specific group of mcu gods there are many more for
different cultures all over the universe that's
a big thor love and thunder plot point because
gore the god butcher christian bale's character
basically takes it on himself to go around killing
all the legit mcu gods of the mcu that's part of
the reason why they're waiting on the thor trailer
because they want people to see the moon knight
episodes first and learn a little bit about the
mcu gods or some of the mcu gods before they give
them like the full crash course during thor love
and thunder but like i've explained before there
are mcu cosmic beings who can become legit gods
through different actions different artifacts odin
is a good example of that but gods can actually
biologically have children and pass a measure
of those god tier powers on to their biological
offspring so that's how thor and hella got special
powers that other asgardians don't have because
odin started out being just a really powerful
cosmic being went through a bunch of trials that
they talk about during norse mythology those
actually happened in the mcu he gained extra power
and became a lesser god the faith of his followers
and then when he had children he just passed on
that power to them and that's how thor and hella
were born gods but typically mcu gods are actually
brought into existence through the collective
unconscious of enough followers that all believe
the same thing so if more people believed
in conscious more people believed and admit
they would grow more powerful if fewer people
believed in them they would grow less powerful
regardless of which dimension they existed in
really good example of that is actually the man
gog from the thor comics too just another really
powerful character who comes into existence
because enough races inside the thor comics
get so pissed at the gods that they want revenge
in that revenge takes physical form in the form
of the man gog if you read the berserk manga or
you watch the anime it's kind of like that too
with the idea of evil technically that's meant
to be the one true god of the berserk multiverse
it's brought into existence through the collective
unconscious of all the people that exist in those
universes so a lot of god's powers become based
on what their followers believe their powers to be
but while marc spector or steven grant is in this
other void this alternate dimension where they've
gone to and seeing them he's really just seeing
their representations kind of like their force
ghosts to make a star wars example in the mcu
the rules are kind of the same like we'll call
them lesser gods so when they want to walk around
physically inside the mcu technically they have to
contain like all this god tier power to this small
physical form when they change form or when they
die it's a little bit different like they kind
of turn into force ghosts odin dying is a good
example of this during thor ragnarok what you're
seeing here as his physical body sort of gives out
is his physical body transforms into pure odin
force energy that's what you're witnessing god
tear energy and it kind of just drifts off into
nothingness as this form basically transfers
itself to the realm of valhalla which is kind of
like a different dimension for these characters
in the mcu whereas khonshu and the rest of his
pantheon ahmed all decided to go to this other
different dimension based on their faith called
other voids that's why this place looks kind of
like an egyptian pyramid as they've explained in
the moon knight series so far they basically trap
themselves inside this alternate dimension mostly
to police themselves like it's the rules that they
created for themselves but also because they
don't really care about humans anymore because
humans kind of turned away with them with the
rise of technology and the only way for them to
come back into the mcu is to basically reverse
force ghost them basically find their physical
remains their bones when they were walking
around physically in the mcu and reconnect
their god-tier souls across dimensions into those
physical remains which should also work for odin
too like you could bring odin back from
his pocket dimension version of valhalla
i'm sure thor and valkyrie have probably thought
about it at some point but the problem is we saw
his entire physical body turn into the odin force
so there are no odin bones inside the physical
mcu that you could use to do this kanju could also
come back just like ahmed the same way that arthur
harrow was talking about but even though he's a
terrible god like we saw at the end of episode 2
kind of loathes humans and mistreats all of his
avatars he's still better than what ahmet plans
to do killing all these people on this version of
earth and then eventually the rest of the universe
a lot of episode three also seems like it's more
of marc spector and stephen grant working on their
relationship both of them trading the body back
and forth trying to help each other and stephen
grant just in general learning more about what
happened to them when they died the first time
and how they made the bargain with khonshu steven
grant also knew a lot about egyptian history he
was learning things but he thought that it was
all mythology so we'll see him learning more about
khonshu and how the other gods are real and what
the rules of being an mcu god are i'm not totally
expecting to get khonshu's entire backstory in
every little explainer behind their pantheon in
next week's episode but he's a little bit like
thor and loki with the rest of their family i
say he's a little bit more like thor because he's
biologically related to the rest of his pantheon
and they think that he's really irresponsible
and they've kind of banished him temporarily so
i think part of the idea is that he'll gain a
measure of redemption and slowly gain back the
acceptance of the rest of his pantheon the way
that thor eventually did during thor ragnarok
really cool connection to black panther and thor
love and thunder to khonshu who we just got done
seeing is also the brother of the panther goddess
bast the one worshipped by black panther's tribe
in wakanda where they get all their powers
from they actually commune with her using the
heart-shaped herb that's why when he goes to the
ancestral plain he sees all these representations
of people as panthers supposedly we're going to
see a version of her actually in thor love and
thunder because of the whole gore of the god
butcher storyline so eventually we'll see a
version of bast i know there are lots of questions
about what's happening in black panther too we'll
talk more about that when they start releasing
footage it also sounds like what happened at
the end of episode 2 is that marc spector revealed
that he'd always had multiple personality problems
since he was a child like steven grant had existed
since he was a child inside his mind but before he
died the first time he just done a really good job
of keeping his personality suppressed inside his
mind so that other people didn't realize that
there was a stephen grant and that's why layla
his wife in present day is only learning about
stephen grant now because he blames khonshu in
what happened with their first death making the
bargain for the weakening of the barrier and
that's why they keep switching between different
personalities now how long you've been doing this
i don't know a long time it's a long time we've
always managed to keep a wall between us but
something's changed the one who controls the
bodies becomes stronger a lot of you also asked
if they're going to be some shadow knight easter
eggs in the series too because the way they're
using the arthur harrow character there is a more
evil version of moon knight called shadow knight
in the comics he's played by marc spector's
brother who gains the powers of country like
kind of takes them from marc spector arthur harrow
has these god tier powers as the avatar of ammit
he was the former avatar of khonshu as he
explained so there might be some shadow
knight easter eggs for him like a crazier
version of moon knight if that's possible
but everybody post your theories in the comments
below eventually we will see what these actual
mcu gods will look like and learn more about the
rules behind them my full moon knight episode 3
video will post next week i got a whole bunch
of marvel videos planned congratulations luis
lujan you're the giveaway winner from my last big
moon knight video please email me on the about
page of my channel so i can get your contact
details everyone click here for my full moon
knight episode 2 video and click here for my new
doctor strange 2 trailer video in easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!